you think francis has an argument
you think francis has an argument on
saying i'm not never going to fight for
500 000 or 600 000 anymore because
here's what the article says
it says naganu
details convo with dana white clarifies
contract by the way he tom just pulled
up the ebitda which was emailed to tyler
in a moment tom if you can explain to us
what that means we'll go through that
here in a minute but uh nagano has
revealed what was said in a recent
conversation with dane white and also
clarifies his contract status and ufc if
he defeats uh cyril uh gain next weekend
speaking with you espn thursday nagano
shared more intimate details of their
conversation and went pretty well at
this point i'm not upset i'm kind of
chill about everything and i went to him
we wish every each other happy holidays
and i tell him my frustration i
expressed to him how i would like to
stay with the ufc but i don't feel like
ufc still wants me to stay so i don't
feel promoted anymore i mean maybe i'm
wrong with about that and i don't see
anything compared to what happened to
different fighters when i asked dana uh
white in response to his observation
dana nagano praised the ufc boss for
being quick on his feet he bring up
uh something really fast and that's why
you know that dana white is very good he
tells me like yeah we want you have you
ever wanted to go somewhere and we
didn't take care of you i'm like yeah
but i think it's more than that anyways
they went back and forth all this i've
had this contract since 24 2017 and i
think you know the 500 600 000
to nagano him getting paid 500 600 you
think he's getting underpaid you think
he's getting paid the right amount
who's got the better argument because i
got a follow-up to that for you
uh he should definitely get paid
um over 600 thousand dollars because
when you look at his his value when it
comes to um if he wasn't in the ufc
right say you know they walked and he
went their separate ways
he can do a boxing match with you know
uh
um
tyson fury tyson fury uh you know
deontay walther and get paid millions
and millions of dollars do you think
dana cares
yes i think dana cares
meaning you think
you think dana cares
that deont that he could go and fight
one of those guys make five to ten
million to the point where he'd be
willing to match that pay to keep him
there
he he knows his value he knows what he
has in in ganu okay and he knows that um
but do you know what i'm asking like
yeah you know like for example i
remember one time shaq went to
pat riley and he says listen man you
know
miami heat you know 20 million a year
and he called jerry buss he says jerry
you know it's me or kobe man miami wants
to give me 20 million you know what
jerry told him he said take it he said
because i'm not going to pay 20 million
i said go take your go get your money so
when he got his 20 million dollars
because shaq was at his end of his uh
right career second dude i'm not going
to pay 20 million and jerry banked on
uh what do you call it uh kobe at the
time rather than paying uh shaq but in
this case isn't francis like at his peak
like isn't he like at a he's still got a
few more years where he can go like this
right he can sell out arena sell out
pay-per-view absolutely and here's the
thing about it like when you look at a
heavyweight that can do what francis
does
it's it just makes the whole league look
better because you know
there can be a lot of great fighters in
other different weight classes but
heavyweight just says something you know
the baddest man in the world has to be a
heavyweight it just kind of like it just
seems like that's just the right thing
to be right you know uh no matter how
good somebody is at 155 he's like yeah
he's tough but i mean i probably can
whoop his ass you know what i'm saying
like nagano would whoop conor mcgregor
i mean that's just but there's no
there's no doubt when you see francis
fight and you see him punch somebody
that you know that he'll probably knock
your head off into a stratosphere you
know there's that fear factor so
having a heavyweight that can do what
francis does is is not you know not
something that you just want to let go
and that's something that you value uh
somebody who can close off the show
somebody who's going to bring you so
here's my follow-up to that and this is
this is where i'm curious to know what
you would say about this because
you know so you got a uh francis who is
a great fighter but he's not a promoter
so he's not a guy that's going to go out
there and promote like let's just say
conor will promote right a massive
developer promote a kobe will promote
usman is not even a promoter usual is a
great fighter but this one is not a
like
you know people who want to watch us mom
fight is because they want to see this
guy see if somebody can take him down
they're not going to because he's a
great promoter he's doing it he's not
that guy he just comes shows up does his
job and matter of fact i don't even
think promoting is natural to him right
i think it's natural to certain people
do you think to dana dana's
dana's a guy to build as the face of ufc
is more somebody that's also great
personality promoter rather than
somebody that just shows up and fights
yeah i mean i think there's a balance
there you know what i'm saying i think
that you know in certain fighters
everybody can't be the same you know if
everybody was the same and everybody
went out there and they talked trash and
they you know tried to sell us and
become very monotonous and boring at the
same time because everybody's giving the
same thing but there's a subtle
confidence in francis and there's just
this
i wonder what's going to happen when he
connects you know like this week this
fight is coming up this weekend you know
he's saint francis isn't saying much but
at the same time the anticipation for it
is very high you know you have serial
gun in there and you have francis and
ghana these guys are training partners
you know uh france's old training
partner is now serial gun trainer
partner and then there's this whole
history about you know francis may have
knocked him out in training practice and
whatnot so there's an anticipation and
there's many different ways to sell a
fight you know if if i'm a promoter
i understand who i'm promoting you know
sometimes guys need a less of a push
than other guys the guys who need more
of a push then that's when you have to
start being a better promoter and get
the people that want to see him yeah and
also you've got guys like khabib you've
got guys like george st pierre some of
the biggest fighters of all time don't
have to go out there and act like clowns
it's not the wwe some of those guys that
aren't the great fighters that kind of
know a little bit this is my moment i
better get the most out of it those are
the guys that go out there and then you
have like a connor who's probably better
on the mic than he is in the ring so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you